on this episode we talk about switching
from account to account to account on
the gram we talk about some t Swift and
crossroads music and we talk about other
stuff you ask questions and I answer
them
this is the askgaryvee show
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 67 of
the ask gary vee show feeling a little
bit better from my post Super Bowl
meltdown mentally that being said I
don't know if you guys caught this and I
think there's some you know content
content content like didn't even take a
shower my hair look like crap
like like I wasn't in the best mood but
many people on the Twitter and in the
comments talked about that being their
favorite episode yesterday and I think
it had to do with actually good answers
that tie-in thing I did which is awesome
big shout out to everybody who's
listening on the podcast but noticing
there's a little momentum going on there
and still really debating if I should do
some original content on the podcast and
are we gonna do the snapchat original
content today are we gonna answer a
couple quick really quick I whether it's
today or not maybe tomorrow
let's do tomorrow 68 feels wait first
episode 68 to do something special
because I think that we're gonna start
doing some original answer is just on
snapchat stories so follow me on the
snapchat and and I'm excited about that
so we continue to innovate and I'm in a
really good mood so let's get into
Episode six seven Rob asks on Facebook
the separate business pages are easy to
handle on Twitter I can switch between
accounts on my iPhone with ease but not
on Instagram
do I need separate accounts that the app
hasn't made it easy to handle or is
there a way to successfully use one
account for all three things without it
being jumbled and ineffective Rob is a
tremendous question and what I love
about this show somebody in the comments
said this is becoming more like a master
class mentorship and I think it's
because we're doing very specific
questions that's what's great about QA
Oh couple things by the way real quick
d-roc Stefan team everyone great new
video that just came out about stuff
you're given Stefan the credit give us a
font right cuz you did the new Twitter
one that's about to come out later today
too as well we are crushing the video
game show Stefan and he's looking Sivan
you look at him with the camera it's
like a little meta thing going on
let's link that up right here will the
Twitter video be up by the time this
episode goes up great let's put that
over here and that one's for you Dirac
and so a couple of new videos and why I
love Twitter video and more importantly
because it's just true more importantly
the one is greater than zero thesis
these videos are great they're top-line
thinking this show is great because it's
practitioner let's get to the answer
because I'm being long-winded here you
know Twitter and Facebook do make it
easy
instagrams newer even though it's become
humongous people forget how young the
company is and you know it's a pain in
the ass much like was the painting asked
for me with Wine Library and Gary
Vaynerchuk Gary Vee and on Facebook when
I used to have personal pages before fan
pages existed and I maxed out my friends
limit that was a humble brag and yeah so
it's a pain in the butt but I think you
should separate the three Instagram has
become a safe haven for people to
consume content they don't want ads they
don't want to see things they don't want
to see and I think it's actually very
important on Instagram specifically for
you to segment out all three I do think
over time Instagram will figure that out
as evolves as a product or maybe not
because they want to make that friction
so people aren't hitting it too hard
from too many different directions but
to answer question practically you need
to create the three accounts and it's
gonna be a pain in the butt because you
got to sign out sign back in but it's
not really that tough rafael asks they
say you should hire slow and fire quick
how many chances do you give your staff
well it's funny on this show multiple
times I talk about the not being
crippled by hiring somebody because if
they're not good I'll fire the truth is
I have struggled for 15 plus years in my
career at least twenty to thirty seven
I'd say for the first 15 years of my
career I was not doing a good enough job
in the firing department and it still is
something I struggle with you know it's
just not fun there's nothing worse than
firing somebody there's nothing good
about it I usually spend an extra twenty
to thirty days
just figuring out the justification of
like what like oh but they were you know
I'm like literally making up stuff to
make myself feel better about it so the
truth is the really ups are for me is
we're slow to it even you know it's one
of things I'm trying to get this company
better at is him don't worry any
vaynermedia people hunting but like you
know like yeah I mean look it I
definitely come to learn that you're
doing the right thing for them as well
because you're just dragging out the
process and they're not growing and
nothing good is gonna come of that but
the answer practically is I my intuition
I really do like you just have to make a
gut call sometimes on can you give this
person one more chance we are not in the
one two or even three strike policy here
at Vayner we have enormous continuity
and some of it has to do with the way we
fire in my opinion I think people see us
trying to handle things with empathy and
grace and one thing I'm very proud of is
when people are let go here people
aren't that surprised right and so
people are paying attention but you
don't want to hold on too long because
then you lose the trust of all the great
people and so um you know I don't think
there's a set answer you got to go on
your intuition I think the more
interesting answer is do you think you
have the EQ and the people skills and
the intuition to do it and if you don't
who do you think has it and empower them
to do it that's the more interesting
part and by the way that could go left
field I would tell you that if I didn't
have that skill in my early days Wine
Library I would have courted my mother
to come in and be that person because I
knew she could do it so even think
outside of your employee base it might
be a friend who is not happy in their
job but you know they have the best
people skills you've ever seen and maybe
you bring them in for a pseudo HR doing
other things and you want them to handle
that it's a the firing process is
immensely important in every
organization one that I don't think
people put enough emphasis on and
there's a lot of angles it's not just
firing fast it's not just not firing
it's how you fire we've been letting
some people go least recently throughout
the last three or four months and I
usually am not that close to it anymore
because I'm very much trying to scale
this but I make sure that I reach out a
week or two later when I find out to
that person and thank them for if they
were here for a day all those things
matter Ashley asks do you think brands
need to be represented across all social
platforms or just the most popular ones
ashlee good job by the double
enforcement because he put up the
Instagram but you also hit me up on
Twitter and said yo answer my question I
like that gusto way to get it girl I do
not think that any break that every
brand in business should be on every
platform
I actually don't also think that they
should be just on the popular ones if
you do not know how to communicate or
your audience is not there for example
if you sell mattress if you sell adult
diapers I would argue that snapchat is
not going to kill it for you even though
it is massively popular right if you
sell to selfie sticks that are only made
that are pink and only marketed to
fifteen-year-old girls you know Facebook
starting to become a place where you can
debate is not really for you and so I
think you need to be in the right place
regardless of its size Yik yaks not the
biggest but I think a lot of college
campus Pizza Shops should be all-in on
that right so it's not the size of the
platform something funny about that it's
not the size of the platform and it's
definitely not on everything it's what's
right for your business based on who you
are trying to reach and so if you're
looking to try to reach 60 year old grey
haired business executives you got to
look at LinkedIn with a much more
crucial eye than on Instagram if you're
trying to reach 25 to 45 year old women
now you get into the Instagram Facebook
game for sure and a little bit less
Twitter definitely Pinterest as well so
if you're trying to reach you know 28
year old dudes Pinterest not as much
right so you've got to understand the
demo you've got to reverse engineer the
demo you're selling to or you're
aspiring to sell to and that's where you
need to story tell around the attention
graph of that person predicated on the
platform that most matters Jonathan asks
I important wines from Italy and salvia
EECOM and through distributors currently
focusing on obtaining new distribution
and a fall behind on the econ side
question what percentage of my time
should be split between each side of the
business and what's a good way to
balance the two
you know Jonathan it's interesting I'm
trying to give them a general answer to
the whole market but I know your
business so well when you're importing I
don't know what state you're in but when
you're doing e-commerce are you selling
to the end consumer because you can't do
that in New Jersey or New York are you
in a state maybe he's in California
Carmen Lynch I think does do that so I
think he can I think in California was
about to say that thanks India in
California cos criminal inch does this
you're able to actually sell to the
consumer and also sell to distributors
you know to me if you can sell ecommerce
100% you're no dope you know you're
making 50 cents more on every dollar by
selling that way than selling to
distributors but what you know is you're
not that big and you don't you're not
necessarily a retailer by trade and it
takes a lot of money and skill to be
able to be a good retailer to sell
enough where the distributors are giving
you the buying power so my strategy for
you this is now I'm giving you as black
and white strategies I've given on this
shows history you know 80% to the
distributors 20% of your time energy and
money to the consumers once you get that
established you spend every minute to
turn that into 70/30 6040 5050 6040
70/30 8020 90 10 maybe maybe 8020 right
because you want to get some restaurants
and key retailers to bring some
awareness to it and for everybody who's
watching the reason I'm giving him that
advice is he just makes more money if he
sells it direct
he's also far more in control where you
saw the distributor's that may be giving
a deal to a retailer that retailer sells
a cheap and then all of a sudden screws
up the pricing in the market and so
that's the answer
oh by the way by the way before you've
done editing here do you recommend the
next one let's turn this show into Mort
and like that was fun that was super
specific and I'm good enough to try to
make it general because I gave a thesis
there like when you control it versus
when you don't but like I'm super pumped
if you want to go on the Instagram and
this is how you give a question let's
put a link up here because I want more
Instagram photos to get on the show to
ask a question you can go very specific
don't feel the pressure of making a
broad if you're like how do I pick this
needle out of this haystack in my farm
in Nebraska and Chauncey Nebraska with
my pig named Don I mean go detailed
there was a weird example but you get
the gist
Casey asks
hey Gary I'm smiling in this pic but
really I'm holding back tears and my
heart is heavy because Seahawks lost and
I bet $225 I've listened to Drake the
weekend jhene aiko and even
partynextdoor but the pain is too much
how do I cope Casey I hear you man I've
got a couple pieces of ice you know you
should probably do what I do which is
heavy rotation of two songs one from
bone thugs-n-harmony and one from
t-swift put those on loop back and forth
go about 17 t-swift 7 crossroads you
know you know 7 mortise with like you
know kind of like 717 7 7 7
it's sevens are good listen to them on
repeat drown your sorrows
then take the pain and put in this very
special compartment right put the pain
in the compartment and build on that
pain every time you have pain put it in
there and let that be an engine for the
revenge that you will strike against
your enemies that's what I'm doing in
football question of the day I expect
you to the watch to the to the just
leave it to rock I expect you to watch
the 1 is greater than 0 video and I
would like you to critique it give me
your two cents on the one is greater
than video in the comment section and by
the way I do appreciate the critiques
something that had brought this up once
before something that happened on Wine
Library TV that is not happening on the
askgaryvee show is people were not so
listening to just answer the question of
the day they were also critiquing the
show going a little deeper into
questions I'd like to see that compound
a little bit more in the community so
take that into consideration hardcore
hardcore hardcore internation people
that's right what about do we have the
response we have the ving tradition
nation wristbands the green ones right I
want to start randomly awarding some
people that are doing the right things
in the comments with like so as in fact
give me a favorite over the next week or
two watch the community comments section
see who you like what's going on reach
out to them directly and and and get
their address and let's send out some
wristbands get into that you keep asking
questions
Oh
yeah that was fun I smiled too because
d-roc smile he knew exactly what I was
doing
India smile did you like more content